єнот Привіт Давно не бачили мені друже
як
в тебе справи Нормально це десь все ж
хотів уже думаю уже ж пора закінчувати
війну пора уже цих виганяти і їхати
додому а Бачиш трошки затягнулася але
нічого то есть ну якби і кажуть що війна
з правого молодих Але ми теж дядьки на
щось в цьому десятку на щось скажемо так
згодні то нормально То есть потрошку
десь їздимо лупимо
потім тренуємося знову їздимо Лохове і
нормально все іде по плану А де ми зараз
знаходимось
ми зараз знаходимось в лісах Я б сказав
так недалеко недалеко десь до лінії
фронту Я б сказав так
заходимось в лісах непогана такий воздух
тут скажемо пташки ранком щебечуть от
тренуємось потихеньку
А до чого тренуєтесь треба уже гнати от
готуємось до контрнаступу Я думаю що все
у нас вийде А коли буде контрнація
Це військова Таємниця тому трошки
почекайте трошки небагато часу
залишилось
скажи що ми сьогодні вам е-е привезли Ну
це вже знаєш як входить в традицію то
есть коли
перший раз ми зустрілися то есть І
привезли ми її генератори нам і
радіостанції От і привезли нам е-е Дафи
і колеса привезли А сьогодні все вообще
баня для пані для солдата це вообще
велика штука тобто бути чистеньким Ти ж
знаєш єнот-полоскун Він завжди щось
полоще То есть вот оця баня буде просто
нам заслегідно з і буду чистити завдання
будуть по праті то есть тому що там цих
банях є ще і пральні машинки і сушилки
от буде вообще идеально А ще привезли то
що ми просили Це ваші знамениті шини бо
якщо чесно весь підрозділ їздить на цих
шинах і скажу відверто півроку як вони у
нас Ми просто дуже задоволені тому що
машина прохідна стає з ними машина іде
мягко бо і дуже-дуже все гарно